Good afternoon.
Welcome to this
Advances in Organized Research sessions.
So the session is about gastric and gastroesophageal cancer
dynamics, including pre-cancer evolution,
metastasis, microenvironment, and therapeutic breakthrough.
This is my disclosure.
So gastric and gastroesophageal and esophageal cancer are
very important cancers because there are more
than a million case newly diagnosed each
year and associated with very high mortality.
The TCGA has published a very nice paper
about the molecular subtypes along the whole upper
gastrointestinal tract, from the esophagus to the
gastroesophageal junction, down to the stomach.
And up in the esophagus is mostly esophageal squamous cell
carcinoma, which is a kind of very different tumor,
whereas down in the gastroesophageal junction, you begin to
see the predominance of the CIN subtypes
of adenocarcinoma. When
we progressively move up into the upper
gastric body
and antrum, the diversity of the cancer become
increased, where
there are some very gastric-specific subtypes like the
EBV-associated gastric cancer, the
genomically stable, or
with substantial overlap with the diffuse histology types of
cancer, and the MSI cancers,
coexist together with the CIN subtype.
So previously, treatment of gastric cancer or
gastroesophageal junction cancer has been really limited
to chemotherapy, mostly based on 5-FU and
platinum. But in the recent year, there has been
increasingly molecular biomarker, like the MSI
subtype,
being respond to PD-1 inhibitions.
The
PRD1 high tumor can be treated by
anti-PD-1 as well. And then the recent emergence
of the claudin 18.2 as a marker for
antibody against it. This is a lineage marker for stomach
tight junction cells. And then there is very exciting
breakthrough in the HER2-positive gastric cancer,
especially those with PD-1
expression.
And we are going to have speaker talking a lot about this,
which is really exciting development.
And there are second-line and third-line treatment, but
the efficacy is really limited, and we still need a
breakthrough in this area.
In parallel, there are technological evolution,
including organoid models, new animal models,
and multiomic profiling, as well as the single-cell and spatial
transcriptomic that allowed us to develop deep
understanding, both in the pre-cancer evolution and
also in the tumor microenvironment.
And with this background, today, we are going to have three talks.
Myself talking about the pre-cancer evolution of the upper
gastrointestinal tract. We have Dr.
Jaffa Ajani from MD Anderson Cancer Center talking about
molecular heterogeneity and also advances in
HER2-directed therapy. We also have Dr.
Yelena Janjigian from Memorial Sloan
Kettering to talk about resectable gastroesophageal
cancer, time to rewrite the standard.
So I'm going to start with the first talk,
and we will have Q&A section after each of the talk, and
also a general discussion for all three of the speaker.
So you can either ask question right at the end or leave it to the end
of the general discussion. So
my laboratory is a molecular pathology
laboratory, and we are interested in the
pre-cancer evolution as well as the molecular
classification of gastric cancer.
More than 10 years ago, we have done a very comprehensive profiling
of gastric cancer and identified these four molecular
subtypes, each having their own driver
mutation, in which now we are seeing emerging targeted
therapy towards each of these molecular subgroups.
So in parallel, we have built organoid model
trying to understand all these molecular subtypes.
And we have now a bank that represent
virtually all the molecular subtype, including some of those that are
previously underrepresented in cancer cell
lines like the ALK fusion model, the RhoA mutation model,
as well as the EBV and
some diffuse gastric cancer models.
In parallel,
there is evolvement of many different
modification to the original organoid cocktail
that adapt to different organs in which you can actually
grow organoid from cancers from these various
organs, epithelial organ especially.
And
in parallel, the exciting development is now
because of this, you can actually grow pre-cancer models
covering all these different organs, and I'm going to mainly cover
the intestinal metaplasia model in this talk.
SoIntestinal metaplasia is the
conversion of gastric cell into intestinalized cells, and
it is usually a consequence of chronic inflammation,
and it has a wide prevalence, especially in
Asian population. Histologically, it has been
classified into the complete and incomplete type, and the incomplete
type is said to be associated with a higher risk of gastric cancer
conversion. However, study of this is
limited because there is no representative sensitive 2D cell line model,
and the animal model, especially in mice, only partially
resemble human metaplasia. And mice
mainly displace the so-called spam instead
of true intestinal metaplasia.
In collaboration with Mike Stratton in Sanger Institute, we have done
a deep
whole genome sequencing by microdissecting individual
crypts in individual gland in the stomach.
And through study of more than 200 whole genome
sequence of individual glands,
we observe the number of
SNVs increasing with age in both
non-cancer and cancer patients. So this is probably the range of
normal, what you would expect. By the age of 80, you will have
around 2,000
SNV mutation in each of the gland in your stomach.
But in some of the gastric cancer patient, we see
outliers with elevated somatic
mutation, and these correlate with chronic
inflammation, denoted in red, and also intestinal
metaplasia. And indeed, if you look at intestinal
metaplasia, for the glands that has it, it has
around two-fold elevation of the SNV and three-fold
elevation of the indel rate.
So this is example of what we have dissected, a
cluster of intestinal metaplasia glands and then some gastric
glands. And when you trace their
evolutionary branch, you can see that all these
metaplastic glands actually comes from a common
ancestor, suggesting that there is actually clonal expansion
from a common ancestor, and the asterisk all along in these trees
would denote intestinal metaplasia.
So this is another example of a bigger piece of
mucosa in which you can see that each of this red
gland denote a metaplastic gland.
You can see families of it around it, but we only dissect
one to represent them. You can see they are completely
independent in terms of their lineage, showing the
heterogeneity, and the field effect is
dramatic. And if you imagine you are a
gastroenterologist, you can biopsy this area in
which you get this IM glands cluster, and this area is a
totally different cluster. And only in this one cm
area of mucosa, you already get, I would suppose
tens or twenties of different metaplastic clones,
each with their own
different driver or different mutations.
So it is a very complex disease because of the
heterogeneity. So this phylogenetic tree shows
each patient in which the glands that we have
microdissected, and you can see the predominant
mutation, this clock line mutation of SBS1 and
5. But you can see in the metaplastic glands denoted
in asterisk, you can see the blue
mutation signature coming off, which is the SBS18,
suggest to be linked to ROS injury.
And then interestingly, this is the indel signature again,
in the metaplastic gland, you see a change in
ratio between the ID2
and the ID1 signature. An ID2 signature
is more enriched in tumor, especially MSI tumor.
So you can see in the early metaplastic process, you
already get this progressive shift in mutational
signature
towards a more like a cancer.
So we have studied extensively the biobank of
organoid that we have collected in which we grow the organoid.
And then with the transcriptome, you can see this is the metaplastic
organoid. This is the reference gastric and colon organoid,
and we characterize them by the colon and the stomach signature
score. And you can see that
for the metaplastic organoids, some of them
actually retain the gastric signature but begin to express
the colon signature, whereas other progressively
get lost in their stomach signature.
So I think this spectrum probably represent
the complete or incomplete transition in the
metaplastic process. And this organoid model, you can see they,
like the glands that we dissect, they have elevated somatic
mutation rates, they have copy number alterations, and these
are the key drivers that we found. They don't
have the very advanced cancer driver like P53
mutation, but ERIT1A mutation is pretty common.
And the most dramatic change is actually in the epigenetics.
So we can see in the metaplastic organoid,
hypermethylation and downregulated gene and
demethylation and upregulated gene.
When we map this to the
genes that related to the gastric or intestinal
signature, actually, we found that some of the
gastric signature genes denoted in black balls here
arehypermethylated and downregulated,
whereas these red genes are denoting the
colon signature are
demethylated
and hyperexpressed.
So the whole process seems to be highly epigenetically
related. So the interesting genes, claudin
18, there is intense interest because the claudin 18.2 is
now a target therapy. You can see they are expressed
in the membrane of the antrum or body organoid,
but in the metaplastic organoid, you can see progressive
reduction in its expression. And
probably this could constitute one of the escape mechanism to
the claudin 18.2 targeted therapy,
where as you can see induction of the metaplastic,
the intestinal signature gene. So we
perform single-cell analysis on the organoid culture,
and you can see if we plot these individual
organoid in the x-y axis, the colon and stomach score,
you can see
the organoid with a hybrid colon and gastric stomach
score are in many of the organoid models.
And here there is a normal gastric cells
contamination, which are the gastric cells that has the
gastric score but very low colon score.
But you can see the heterogeneity in the spectrum.
Some cells has more advanced intestinal differentiation, but other
cells are more hybrid, and the lighter color is
denote the cells after Wnt withdrawal when we try to induce
differentiation. You can see an elevation of their score.
So with this heterogeneity, then we pick
individual clonal organoid and grow them and look at the spectrum
of differentiation, and here is the
proportion of hybrid versus more advanced
intestinal cell in each clonal organoid.
This is the reference gastric organoid.
So you can see individual clone, each could have
different proportion of differentiation into the
hybrid or more advanced intestinal cell.
So suggesting that actually these epigenetic
deregulation constitute a spectrum.
Each cell is different in terms of its epigenetic
setting that whether they display more advanced
intestinal or a more hybrid phenotype.
So when we look at the different cell cluster,
actually the cycling isthmus stem cells of the
body organoid versus metaplastic organoid, you can see the
key difference is the transcription factor of intestinal metaplasia
are being expressed. But when we move progressively
down,
we can see this very interesting group we call pit-enterocyte, in
which
especially after Wnt withdrawal, when they differentiate, these
organoid express the pit cell marker
as well as enterocyte markers. So these constitute the
hybrid cells that we are seeing. But we are also seeing
other population like the cycling tuft
cells, which is quite specific in the stomach, and
then also the secretory progenitor expressed in the
neuroendocrine marker. So with these, we can
construct a 3D lineage
trajectory of the normal gastric organoid versus the
metaplastic organoid. So here you can see the
cycling isthmus stem cell denoted in light green can
goes to differentiate into the gastric mucus cell or through
the cycling tuft cell into the secretory progenitor.
And at the opposite end of the spectrum, these are the
gastric chief stem cells. Whereas in metaplastic
organoid, you can see they are more complex.
So from the cycling isthmus stem cells, they can give rise to the
Lgr5 stem cell and then the brown secretory progenitor.
But on this side, it was the pit-enterocyte and the enterocyte that I
will show you a little bit more in details.
So this is the lineage trajectory of a gastric body
organoid, and this is the cycling isthmus stem
cells, which is very high in STMN1, which is we
feel a very good marker. You can see you can stain them in the isthmus
region, and they correlate with the high
Ki67 labeling index. But
from here you can see that
the gastric organoid would differentiate into the pit
mucus cell characterized by MUC5AC, TFF2 and claudin
18. So these are the gastric marker.
But here is the interesting part, the metaplastic organoid.
So
for the cycling isthmus stem cells, so they still express
STMN1, but they now
express the stem cell, the IM markers.
And then when they differentiate, you can see they can give rise to the
Lgr5 stem cells, which also express the intestinal stem marker.
But on the other hand, they give rise to these two different
arm. One is more hybrid. You can see expression of
enterocyte marker as well as gastric pit
cell marker, which we denote the hybrid cells.
Whereas the other arm show more advanced intestinal
differentiation where you can get the more advanced intestinal
marker, but
reduction or loss in the gastric marker.
So,
in fact, it translate very well histologically for this
hybrid arm to the so-called incomplete metaplasia, in
which you can see theGastric gland expressing
both Fabp, its intestinal marker, and Mu5ac.
And the cells look transparent,
with goblet cell in between, so characteristic of so-called
incomplete IM. Whereas this arm corresponds to the
more advanced enterocyte differentiation, in which the cell
do not express any gastric pit marker at all, but mainly
intestinal markers. So we find that this hybrid cell is
very interesting.
We will
discuss it later.
So here we also try to look at where is the origin of the
metaplastic cells. So in the same
patient, we pool the body organoid and the
metaplastic organoid together to perform a lineage
trajectory analysis. And you can see that the
STM1 cycling isthmus stem cell seems to
be common between the metaplastic
and the
body organoid. But the metaplastic
organoids that differentiate into the
enterocyte on this side and then the Lgr5 stem cell on this
side. Whereas the body organoid differentiate
into the gastric pit cells. So
here, correspondingly immunohistochemically, you can see
that this is the isthmus region with
Cdx1 expression only on the upper part, whereas the lower part
is not. And then you can see the Stmm1
expression here, the upper part with the metaplasia, whereas
the lower part retain the gastric phenotype of
Musix and Progestrine. So suggesting that
actually IM start in the isthmus stem cells and
move progressively upward.
So when we examine the lineage plasticity of these
hybrid cells, here we use the single cell and
delineate their different proportion of
cell types signature. And we find that the
metaplastic cell, apart from expressing both gastric and
intestinal marker, actually
retain other, for example, epithelial
non-GI signature and even some mesenchymal
signature. So they remain high in the
diversity, whereas the advanced intestinal
organoid are more mature and unidirectional into the
intestinal fate, whereas the gastric organoid
unidirectional into the gastric fate.
Interestingly, this arrests in the hybrid state,
apart from display higher lineage
plasticity, also display
a fetal signature reversion. So you can see in this arm
of metaplastic cell, they express this fetal signature, the fetal
gut signature, including Tacstd2, which is also called
Trop2, which is a very interesting target now with
the ADC targeting these
fetal markers.
But beyond this, it also express other fetal marker.
So it looks like this metaplastic process are
actually undergoing fetal reversion with the lineage
plasticity. So lastly, we
examine
whether our IM organoid cell cluster or body
organoid cell cluster are more similar to
the normal or IM gastric tissue or gastric cancer
tissue. So you can see this is normal
gastric tissue. So they preferentially map to the
body organoid tree, whereas the IM gastric
tissue preferentially map into the IM organoid
tree. But interestingly, this is gastric cancer tissue.
You can see they cell map to
body organoid tree, but they map to a lot of the metaplastic
organoid tree where individual nodes denote different cell cluster,
as highlighted in this pie chart. So you can see the gastric
tissue, cancer tissue actually show the
higher similarity to the IM cycling isthmus
stem cell, as well as many different cell cluster in the
metaplastic process. And a minority actually looks
more similar to colon, and only a very small subset
resemble the
body organoid. And you can see in the metaplasia and
gastric cancer tissue, these cells also showed a
elevated fetal and the Yap stemness score.
So,
we then examined the chromosomal
instability status. You can see some of these organoid
display trisomy of chromosome 20,
and as well as in the normal body organoid.
But if you look at the distribution, they are quite widely
dispersed. For example, here you can see a chromosome 20
gain in one of the gland and a chromosome 13 gain in another
gland. So this is another extreme example in a
64-year-old stomach cancer patient.
75% of the gastric gland already acquire an extra
chromosome. So the
orange denote one haplotype and the blue denote the other
haplotype. So you can see these are independent events.
So sometimes it's the paternal, sometimes it's the maternal haplotype that get the
gain. And
it is very widespread. When we date the occurrence of this
chromosomal gain, it actually dates back to
when the patient was very young, and in this case, around 12 years old.
So these are the different cases with the
trisomy, and you can see they all happen in a pretty early
stage.So these
organoids, or these glands,
are wild type for P53. So you can actually see onset of chromosome
instability in a P53 wild type background.
So coming back to the organoid model, we find that the change in the
metaplastic organoid become independent of FGF10,
and they have reduced FGFR2 expression.
And when we examine the organoid with chromosome 20 gain,
we found that they actually can survive without Matrigel for
longer. So, because of this
observation, we start to withdraw the Matrigel, and we
found that in a few metaplastic organoid, we actually
get
growth that can actually grow independent of the Matrigel.
And when we examine them, we call this spheroid.
When we examine them, they actually get even a higher
copy gain in chromosome 20 in some of the case.
But all of them do have chromosome 20 gain.
And we did single-cell analysis, and again, showing the
enrichment of this subpopulation with the
CIN extra gain of chromosome when we put them in Matrigel,
so the whole population is constitute those with chromosome
20 as well as other chromosome gain.
And this is another two cases,
as example.
So,
when we look at this
metaplastic organoid that can survive
without Matrigel, we found that they have increased EMT
markers and stemness, et cetera, and
they also display tumor-like phenotype by the transcriptome.
So,
in summary, whole genome sequencing of microdissected
metaplastic glands revealed increased mutational load,
marked heterogeneity, and parallel evolution of individual clones,
as well as frequent CIN in the absence of P53
mutation. And the organoid biobank can
actually capture these diverse array of metaplastic
gland harboring heterogeneous genetic and epigenetic
perturbations. Single-cell RNA-seq revealed IM
organoids are spanning a spectrum from hybrid to advanced
intestinal differentiation, recapitulating the
incomplete to complete metaplasia spectrum in tissue.
And they show impaired differentiation potential, higher cell lineage
plasticity, as well as fetal reversion.
We have also shown the putative origin of IM from SDMN cycling
isthmus stem cell and gastric cancer cells in tissue show high
similarity to metaplastic cycling isthmus stem
cell and other metaplastic cell populations.
Finally, we identify a link between chromosome 20 gain and cell
matrix independency in metaplastic organoid, potentially
working in concert as one of the earliest tumor-initiating event
in gastric cancer development. So, in
parallel, there is also a very exciting
evolvement of the understanding of the metaplastic process
through spatial and in vivo transcriptomic and
also single-cell analysis. For example, this study
from the Vanderbilt group show that there is, in
parallel to the metaplasia, there is the
PDGF-alpha subset of fibroblasts being
expanded. And co-culture of these metaplastic
fibroblasts can actually promote dysplastic
progression.
And the Singapore Gastric Cancer Consortium has also
published a lot of multi-omics data, including
here suggesting that the intestinal stem cell
is highly linked to early gastric cancer and also
mutational signature of SBS17 in IM
and mutation count, ARID1A mutation, and high clonal
hemopoiesis associated with increased risk of
IM progressions. So I'm going a little bit
out of time now. So,
we start off with pathology. We understand the tumor by
their
morphology, molecular,
underlying genomics. Now we have a living biobank model of all these
organoid. And progressively now we can even capture the
pre-neoplastic organoid. So with these, I think,
there is hope for therapeutic intervention, especially in the
pre-cancer
area. And there has been two
approach previously undertaking, like using an anti-HER2/neu
mythic agent or using a MYC inhibitor
for targeting
pre-cancer. So hopefully with all these, we will see
a
prevention of gastric cancer becoming a good possibility.
So I would like to thanks my collaborators, especially Helen
Yen, who actually co-lead this study with me, and
Sarah and Yintong are the postdoc working on the
metaplastic project, and Mike Stratton, for the
collaboration. So I'm probably running out of time for
questions. So, maybe I will leave it to the last general
discussion, and I would like to invite the second speaker,
Dr.
Ajani.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I want to thank Dr. Leung and
ACR for inviting
me.Can
you put my slides on?
The second talk.
Yeah. Thank you. So I'd like to start with
examples of other tumor types than GEA
to demonstrate
the advancement that has already occurred in the
defining metastatic molecularly.
So this is breast cancer,
and here,
in the metastatic process.
Can you see the pointer? How do you get the pointer?
This is the mouse itself is a pointer.
Yeah. The mouse.
Okay. All right. I'm just going to
talk you through this. So on the right side of the slide, you
see
the preferential mutations that occur in metastatic
breast cancer, particularly ESR1.
And in the middle, you see the copy number variations that have
been defined in metastatic process.
At the bottom right is the various
pathways
have been well defined, and they can be targeted.
In prostate cancer, we heard from Dr. Sawyer today.
On the left side, you have
the primary tumor with a variety of alterations.
But on the right side is the androgen
receptor and P53. And androgen
receptor is amplified in almost 60% to
70% of prostate cancer in certain
organs.
So as far as GEA is concerned, we really don't have this kind
of definition of metastases.
So what we do in the clinic is,
patient comes in with an endoscopic specimen, or we collect them,
and we do profiling biomarkers, NGS,
all this, and then we treat the metastases.
And I'm not suggesting we biopsy all the metastases,
but we haven't really defined them very well, and this may
become important in the future.
So in the interest of time, I was not going to review
the literature by other investigators.
They really contribute a lot to our understanding.
But if you look at the whole picture, it's very limited.
So in 2020, we published this paper
on peritoneal metastasis. We've been working on it for almost 15 years.
And
there you can see on the right side, right lower side,
that if you have peritoneal metastasis and you look at
location of the primary, whether signet ring cells are
present, whether it's a grade two or grade three,
whether it is intestinal type, diffuse type, there's a lot of heterogeneity.
Different genes are expressed.
And we didn't have primary tumor at the time, so we took the
TCGA data, which is entirely from
primary tumors.
And then when we look at the comparison between
TCGA primary tumors from other patients
and then our patients,
there are two genes that stood out.
One is the TAF1 and RPL5, and
these two genes have already been defined by the
pan-cancer as driver
of these tumors.
So we were able to then collect specimen from the
primary tumor,
and here we have 41 patients,
and some healthy donors.
I won't go through all of this because there's a lot of data in this
paper, but we have normal tissue, chronic gastritis,
intestinal metaplasia, primary tumor, liver mets,
peritoneal mets, and ovarian mets from the same patient.
And we are looking at the immune cell and stromal
cell. We're not looking at epithelial cell in this particular
paper. And you can see throughout
that if you look at the primary tumor versus
metastasis,
stage of the tumor
and various features, there are a lot of
differences.
So this is one of the examples
of how diverse
the stromal component, the TME component,
is from the same patient in different locations.
We were also able to define these three ecotypes, I'm sorry,
six ecotypes,
and their
cellular compositions as well as their prognostic value,
and then also whether you can add
immunotherapy and get an advantage.
So these are also widely distributed from the
same patient's tumor in different locations.
And then I think Dr. Lung showed this slide
where we identified SDK, Syndecan2,
in the CAF cells that are highly prognostic in primary
tumor as well as in metastatic tumor.
So at the lower left side,
we have the in vivo model where
you take CAF cells and tumor cells and
co-co-inject them in
mice,
and half of the mice did not get
CAF with syndecan-2.
And on the right
side of the lower left side,
you will see where CAF cells were expressing
syndecan-2, and the tumor grew very rapidly.
So this is just one example of how CAF
can promote tumor progression.
Then more recently, we published another paper in
Gastroenterology. Here we have 20 patients,
stage
four gastric cancer with the primary tumor available,
liver metastasis available, and peritoneal.
And in the second or in the middle, you see the major cell
types. Here we included epithelial cells, so cancer cells are
included.
And then on the right side, if you look at different components such as
blood, adjacent normal, primary tumor, ascites,
and liver metastasis, you can see the compositions.
They are quite different. And this is from the same patient.
This is another example of one patient where
you have the circus plot
predominantly looking at various pairs.
One pair I want to mention is the
macrophages type
two and CD8 positive cells,
and you can see considerable differences.
Then the genius of Pawel Mazur, who is one of our
collaborator,
first established this model of CAR T
cells
in mice using
the mesenchyme as a
target for CAR T. But then he also identified
GPX4
elevation in tumor cells. So
if you look at the mouse panels,
with the CAR T, you get some advantage.
The IKE is the GPX4 inhibitor. But
on the right side of the panel, when you inhibit
GPX4 in tumor cells and then add
CAR T cells, you get dramatic improvement.
So today we heard from Dr. June that if you
inhibit CAF cells and then do CAR T cell,
you get an advantage. Here we are targeting tumor
cells in two different ways.
So in spite of all this heterogeneity, we've been able to make some
advances in the clinic. And you have to wonder, how
does that happen?
Okay, so these are the individuals who have
helped with this. On the left side is my team, and this would not be
possible without Ruping, who's the first author of a couple of papers
I showed you, and Lingua, who is the
bioinformatics
leader.
So,
let me just go on to talk about HER2.
I wasn't going to plan to explain
everything about HER2 because it can take a lot of
time. So let me talk about the new drug, which is a
bispecific antibody,
and that is anidatamab. It's intentionally an
asymmetric
bispecific antibody that tends to
conform to trans configuration. In
trans configuration, it can engage two different
receptors. So one arm will engage one receptor,
another arm will engage another receptor.
And you can see the transmission
electron microscopy on the right side.
So anidatamab can engage two receptors at the same
time, and if you think about thousands of
these bispecifics engaging HER2
receptors
at the same time, you will get cluster formation.
And cluster formation has very specific
consequences that I'm going to mention.
So this is just a trajectory of what can happen when you
inject anidatamab. You engage HER2 receptor.
There is little bit of clustering,
and then
on the right side you have cap formation,
and then finally you have hexamerization of the
molecule. This is very important for
complement-dependent cytotoxicity.
So this is an example of
cap formation. So you have negative control
on the left, and the second lane is anidatamab, and you can
see those silver color
thick caps that are being formed on the surface of
the cell.
And then that doesn't happen with trastuzumab, doesn't happen with
pertuzumab, and doesn't happen with the combination of
trastuzumab, pertuzumab.
So you get this kind of cluster where
the Y
portion of the bispecific is engaged
to the HER2And the
FC portion is sticking out. And so there's
a high clustering of the FC receptors,
and this will invite C1q, which is a
key protein for complement-dependent
cytotoxicity.
So this is another two different methods to
show that zanidatamab
induces high level of
cap formation or cluster formation that other
HER2-directed therapies do not. So you've got control on the
left, two lanes with two different methods.
Zanidatamab, you can
visualize the caps,
and then trastuzumab or pertuzumab and the combination.
So when you have this cluster and hexamerization,
the CQ1 protein really needs to engage
six FC receptors in order to
invite
the C3
protein component to enact
the cytotoxic cell toxicity.
So
as opposed to other HER2-directed
treatments,
zanidatamab can induce ADCC. It
can induce ADCP, which is the macrophages
are engaged. And finally, complement-dependent
cytotoxicity. So there are a number of advantages
for this bispecific antibody that others do not produce.
And as a single agent, this is hard to see, but
the paper is listed at the top, so you'll be able
to get to it. But as a single agent in the fourth,
fifth, and sixth line,
zanidatamab produced a number of responses
that were also lasting for a long time.
This is something we didn't see before
availability of zanidatamab, because trastuzumab cannot
do this, and chemotherapy cannot do this.
Then the phase two, which combined zanidatamab
to chemotherapy,
also produced dramatic clinical responses,
and some of them were very long-lasting.
It produced diarrhea when you combine with platinum
and fluoropyrimidine.
This led to the trial Horizon
GEA-01,
which had three arms. Arm A is the control arm.
Arm B is the zanidatamab with chemotherapy.
So similar to control, except zani
instead of trastuzumab.
And Arm C was zanidatamab,
tislelizumab, and
chemotherapy.
The primary endpoints of PFS as well as
OS.
And this is the PFS
endpoint,
which
the comparison is between trastuzumab chemotherapy
versus zanidatamab chemotherapy.
And you can see on the right upper side
that there is a four-month advantage in
PFS,
which is also quite remarkable. Hazard ratio of
0.65, very strong P value. And you can
see throughout the journey of the patients on
these curves, there is a
considerable separation.
When we look at the other experimental arm to the control
arm, in this case, zanidatamab, tislelizumab, and
chemotherapy,
again the median PFS is similar
with or without tislelizumab, but all the numbers
at different landmarks are better than
you get without tislelizumab.
So the area between the two curves is greater
with tislelizumab than you get without tislelizumab.
So in terms of overall survival,
without tislelizumab, zani plus chemo versus
trastuzumab chemo,
you have
the advantage towards overall survival, but this is
not statistically significant now, but
we expect it to become significant with further
follow-up.
But when you compare zanidatamab, tislelizumab,
and chemotherapy to chemotherapy plus trastuzumab, it
is
statistically significant, 0.72
hazard ratio, seven-month difference in overall survival.
And at every landmark, there is an advantage.
And hopefully, there will be a better tail to the curve
that we normally see with immunotherapy.
So in summary, I think we have made considerable
progress in the arena of HER2 targeting,
especially in the frontline setting.
So,
the second column
where the numbers are either blue or black.
So blue is the experimental arm.
So you saw
10, 12 years ago,
the experimental armThey
had the median survival of
13.8, but also look at the hazard ratio,
0.74.
And then the black numbers are the control.
So if you just run down in the second column to the
black number, you can see even the control is getting
much better. Our patients are doing a lot better in the clinic,
even with the
standard of care treatment.
But the blue also continues to increase.
Same thing for PFS,
et cetera.
So this is my last slide.
We can say that dinutuximab,
with its shortcoming of diarrhea,
and we have to be very vigilant about its management,
should be able to replace trastuzumab.
And perhaps zani, Tisley, and chemo will become the
standard of care. And I didn't show you the data, but this
would be irrespective of PD-L1 expression.
So with that, I want to thank everybody for
being here today. Thank you.
So there is five minutes for question, if you
have questions now.
Yeah.
Can you go to the mic?
Very nice talk. First question to Dr.
Leung regarding the--
Do I pronounce right? I'm not so sure
for you. But I think you both or only
Dr. Johnny's right now, the question.
Yeah. Because for me, leave to the end.
Oh, okay.
Regarding Dr. Johnny, I'm wondering the trial for
HER2, the new antibody, do they have a
biomarker-guided selection patient or all comers?
No, these are patients who are, by definition,
are HER2 positive. So they have to have three-plus protein
expression,
or they can have two-plus protein expression, but they have to have
increased number of ERBB2 copies.
Okay. That mean they have a biomarker-guided, either
amplification or overexpression HER2, right?
That's right. And this is not
highly common situation. It's about 10% to
12% of,
I would say, US patients have HER2 positivity.
Most patients don't.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay, so is there any other question for now?
So if not, maybe we have
the next speaker. Thank you, Dr. Ajani.
So our next speaker-
... is Dr. Elena
Jamcijan.
Well,
thank you for the opportunity, and it's always my
favorite topic, discussion of how we can change
practice for our patients. I am a medical oncologist,
and my focus has really been on bringing new treatments to the patients,
but also being able to learn from every single patient
from our translational program.
And I'll showcase some of the work that my group has done and give
you a little roadmap. Today is the advantage of
we still have the whole weekend of the meeting, so I'll give you a sense of
other abstracts that you may want to focus on.
So of course, we always have to bring it back to the patient.
And increasingly, we are seeing this disease
in younger and younger patient population.
It's not infrequently that I'm seeing patients younger than my age and
often sometimes even closer to the age of my children.
So
this is a typical patient now from my clinic, a 37-year-old man who
presented with months of swallowing difficulty and weight
loss. In these patients, we see delayed diagnosis
because of course, the practitioners
in the community are not
expecting these patients to have cancer.
Eventually, he had a imaging when we usually get FDG PET
scan. Our disease is very
much PET avid, so it lends itself well for functional
imaging. Again, addressing some of the questions that
were raised about ability to detect heterogeneity.
And we also did an EGD, and of course, there's bulky tumor.
And as you could see, it's very visible.
And typical biomarkers we do in the clinic now routinely
are protein-based expression, loss of expression of
mismatch repair protein, gain of HER2 overexpression or
amplification by Fish,
PD-L1 overexpression, and claudin, as well as
Epstein-Barr virus, which can also cause this disease.
So in this patient, this was an MMR proficient tumor, CPS
relatively low, one claudin positive, and again,
overwhelmingly, at least in our clinic,
these are p53 mutant tumors with very aggressive
types of TP53 mutation that do lead to chromosomal instability.
So what we're here today is to talk about curative disease.
What you heard from Jafar is metastatic patients first-line setting.
We're talking about possibility of cure and cure
with patients that they can-- As you know, young people want to just go
back pretending they've never had cancer.
I mean, all of us want to do that, but young people in particular.
So how do we cure more patients but also minimize the
fallout of our treatments? So surgery alone,
at least in the Western population, really
results to minimal likelihood of cure because this is a metastatic
disease at the get-go systemically.
High risk of micrometastasis, even if you can't see them on
imaging.And perioperative chemotherapy improved
survival by a bit, but not sufficiently.
Historically, this was a very fractionated field.
In Asia, people would get surgery first and then have chemo.
In the United States, we did some chemo perioperatively, but again, with very
limited efficacy.
So the big breakthrough in the last year was that we're now able to
unify our approach, and even doctors in South Korea and Japan,
Taiwan, and China are agreeing that doing
chemotherapy and chemo immunotherapy first is the best option,
and this is because of a large phase three study, Matterhorn study,
that changed practice showing that combination of durvalumab with three-drug
chemotherapy, FLOT, improved survival.
The other key feature of the study, in addition to saying
people all over the world can get this regimen, and we can move the field forward
in a
way where the comparator arm is standardized across different
regions. We also showed that if you have a major
pathologic response or a complete pathologic response, this will translate
to survival improvement. In other words, you can have a
quick result and a litmus test that could give you a sense
early, instead of doing a large phase three study, whether or not the treatment
that you're studying in early
phases, phase two perhaps, single center study, you can get a sense
of whether or not you're going to have achieved a
meaningful outcome because these tumors are bulky, and if you're
able to eradicate the tumor, meaning pathologic complete response, which
is we see 19% of the patients with durva plus FLOT,
or even a major pathologic response with less than 10% residual tumor
cells, you're very likely to have a cure.
So it's a very satisfying thing for us to do in the clinic
after the patient is there to be able to tell them the likelihood of
cure is very high and you should not worry.
The other important factor that we did, because there were other
studies trying to study this in adjuvant setting, we
demonstrated that neoadjuvant treatment is very important.
After the diagnosis, everyone has to calm down,
stop, and actually not do surgery, because that was a very
counterintuitive thing to do for the surgeons, certainly even for
the patients. Once the patient is diagnosed and if they're healthy, they just
want the tumor out in the bucket somewhere.
But that's not the right thing to do. We were doing it all wrong.
Taking the cancer out is a bad move because first you don't have
the tumor in place to know that what you're doing is successful,
right? You're only treating a hypothetical
MRD sort of setting. But also you're removing the
education, the educator, the tumor from
the patient and the amount of
antitumor immune response,
and diversity of that response is really
impaired if you're taking the cancer out.
So everyone just needs to sort of
take a breath, send the patient to the medical oncologist
to be able to improve the chances of cure.
So let's go back to our patients. So we know then we can impact
improved survival in some patients, and this is actually the patient that I was
showing you.
I got his permission to share. He's very proud of his outcome.
He had a complete response. So he had FLOT, durva,
went on to have a YPT zero and zero tumor,
and unfortunately, we took his esophagus and GE junction out anyway,
so he had an Ivor-Lewis esophagectomy and went through a
horrible divorce through the whole thing, through the treatment, and now he comes
back four years later, cured. The only thing he complains about is
having to sleep on a wedge and also the dating scene in
New York. So it's very tough, apparently.
But I think in this patient, if we knew he was going to be a complete
response, perhaps we could have left him with his
organs in place. I think he would want that.
So the next frontier is to figure out who are the complete responders that we can
leave and deescalate and do organ preservation.
Perhaps we don't need to develop grade two neuropathy and not be able
to text because of all the chemo we're giving them, and on
whom we can escalate the therapy.
So, you will see a great presentation
on Tuesday during the plenary on the updates of the
INFINITY study. I'm not going to spoil everything, but I did want to
showcase the work that was done by Gano group, which was very
important, showing that the total neoadjuvant
immune blockade with dual immune checkpoint blockade using tramidurva
can spare patients, and you can do organ preservation
in early-stage gastric cancer. In fact, again, going
back to my whole point of doing
all the work while the tumor is in place is critical because we actually did a
study at MSK where we said, "Okay, most
MSI tumors are cured with surgery alone.
So if they already had their surgery and they did not get neoadjuvant
immunotherapy, and if they're MRD positive," which
happens in about 15% of patients, in other words, after surgery, they're
ctDNA positive, "let's give them immunotherapy and let's see how they do."
Well, we did. We gave them pembro, and we did well.
We cleared everyone's ctDNA. But as you see here from the
curve on the right, 38% of patients still recurred
despite ctDNA clearance at six months.
So again, showing that once you're MRD positive, and
if even in MSI tumors in adjuvant setting, you're treating
metastatic disease. So you really need to focus on these tumors
while they're still in place and risk stratify better.
And I think in MSI tumors in particular, dual immune checkpoint blockade
may be sufficient.So what are we doing?
You just heard nice focus on zanidatamab data.
While KEYNOTE-811, of course, changed practice in metastatic setting
several years ago. So we're taking the KEYNOTE-811 regimen, which
is the pembrolizumab, trastuzumab, FLOT regimen, to
early-stage disease in neoadjuvant setting.
And the key points of this study is that we're giving even more
treatment neoadjuvantly while the tumor is in place.
So instead of doing only four cycles of chemoimmunotherapy and HER2
therapy, we're doing six, and that's been tolerable.
And the protracted course of neoadjuvant therapy allows a
maximum time for tumor response and again to mount the
anti-tumor immune response. And again, similar to other approaches
now, we're allowing non-operative management. Patients expect it.
In fact, if you do not have a non-operative management in your
consent form, it makes it a difficult consent form to sign with the
patient. They want to at least have an option.
And of course, longitudinal sample collections is critical in this study.
So what we already saw, and initially we had a doublet regimen,
CAPOX, compared, and then we amended the study.
So this is not randomized by any means, but just showing you here to give you
a sense of what we saw.
Excitingly, we already seeing 83% complete
clinical response. So small numbers, early data, but
FLOT pembrolizumab is very doable and it's doable
with six cycles per op. And CAPOX, again,
underperformed. So we won't have time to talk about it, but
the combination with taxane does something to tumor
microenvironment that makes the responses deeper
and more likely to have complete response.
So what we're trying to generate now is finish this data set.
It's going to be important for translational work, but also
develop non-operative management strategies to stratify to know
upfront which patients will be non-responders.
The good news is out of our cohort of patients, everyone who had a
complete response, there were only three people who elected to have
surgery.
They also had pathologic complete response.
So at least using our modern tools of endoscopies, PET scans,
serial biopsies, and ctDNA, we're good at saying that a clinical
complete response translates to pathologic complete response.
So now, of course, the portfolio is expanding.
AstraZeneca has an important study looking at other biomarker
selected strategies using claudin
ADCs, HER2 ADCs, and of course, combination
of
bispecifics all in perioperative setting, building on the Matterhorn
strategy. And we're doing an institutional
small study, a single institution study, kind of Matterhorn
accelerated, looking at PD-1/CTLA-4 bispecific
with catumaxomab.
So what worries me though is, of course, not
the over-treatment, because that's important, but also the
patients who are not responding, right?
We talk about de-escalation, but what do we do for the majority of
patients who will not be
achieving complete response or major pathologic response?
Who are those patients? How can we help them?
Well, so we know that the big bad elephant in the room,
and this is data we published from CheckMate 649, which was a large Phase
3 study, showing that majority of chromosomally unstable tumors,
which is the cancers that we see in the West predominantly,
don't benefit from immune checkpoint blockade in first-line setting.
The hazard ratio is 0.92. The dogma is all to
focus on PD-L1, and people will fight to death about
what cutoff of CPS one to four or CPS less than
3.5 we should use. But really the elephant in the room
is that it's
something beyond PD-L1, and PD-L1 is just
another sort of easy thing that we can assess.
But chromosomal instability drives immune evasion in
many of our patients that we're seeing in the clinic.
So this is plug number one for one of the
talented bioinformaticians and scientists that work with my lab.
So Jerry Zhu is presenting this abstract today
looking that, of course, everything is a spectrum.
Nothing is as simple as just calling someone chromosomally unstable tumor.
And we identified six reproducible CIN
architecture
features that define aneuploidy, focal amplification, and
subclonal evolution. And really the purpose
of this exercise was to use the facet analysis
from close to 2,000 cases that we already did at
MSK, but also the huge rich database of the
CheckMate 649 whole exome data that BMS shared with
our group to
put in a framework, a unified clinical molecular framework to
standardize how do we define CIN assessment to enable
clinical patient stratification in the future, both in first
line, second line, but also in early-stage tumors.
The other important feature we saw is that in patients-- So
we've been using chemoimmunotherapy in early stage disease well before
the approval
based on Matterhorn. So we amassed quite a group
of patients
mostly in standard practice who got chemoimmunotherapy.
Now we're seeing some of the recurrences.
So
Dr. Chak and my group looked at genomic instability and
predicted recurrence after perioperative immunotherapy in
gastroesophageal cancer. So check out the poster.
This small snippet of the data does not give it justice,
but there is a story on, again, giving chemoimmunotherapy
while the tumor is in place still, and even
inducing a second immune response after recurrence,
how CIN tumors affect that, and how the timing
and duration of treatment
may be important. So this is an important factor
for us to consider, particularly since, of course, in the age of Matterhorn, we
have to decide what to do with these patients when they
recurSo what we're also seeing is
that even if you induce-- So once you've been immune,
sort of exposed, and if you're trying to induce a second response,
sustained treatment induces increase in interferon gamma, but it
does not-- So you're seeing what you would think would be
adequate response,
but it does not translate to clinical benefit.
And this is from a phase two study that Sam Citrin in my group
is running. Again, come check it out.
This will be April 20th at 2:00 PM.
So why is that? Well, what we're seeing, and I know
Sam Baccom and Ashley Loughney gave a great talk yesterday, but
chronic tumor cGAS associated with immunovasion and poor
survival, and it's important, particularly in our cancers.
This is data from breast cancer showing that if you have acute cGAS
activation, it's potentially a good thing and can induce immune
response. But what we often do, and what happens in the setting of
CIN tumors, it burns out to chronic activation, which actually
causes suppression of STING, and as a result,
immunovasion. And this data from breast cancer patients
showing that if you have, as you see here on the bottom
red survival curve, cGAS high and low STING,
it's a really bad thing for patient survival and outcomes.
And now we're seeing the same in gastroesophageal cancer.
Again, we see chronic cGAS high tumors,
and we're seeing STING low. And what we're also seeing is
there's a tumor stromal uncoupling between cGAS-STING axis,
where we're seeing different expression.
And I think what earlier discussion about heterogeneity and
importance of tumor microenvironment in the stroma.
In fact, again, going back to are we really looking at the right
biomarkers, cGAS-STING activation appears to be, at least in our
limited cohort that we looked at so far, a stronger predictor of poor
prognosis in patients treated with immunotherapy
than chromosomal instability itself.
So considering it's potentially a
druggable target, it's really important for us to continue to study this and
characterize it.
We're all together,
sort of international group of researchers focused in
the global engine for target discovery.
MSK is just
epicenter of it because we happen to both to have a big translational
program, but also run phase three studies.
And it's great to be able to collaborate with several industry
partners who are then able to share with us raw data from some of
these studies and use it for target discovery using
newer AI tools within silica medicine, but also
global collaborations. So we meet twice a year.
It's both in person and virtual, and if you're interested, please feel free
to ping me, and you'll be invited to the group.
Our next retreat is coming up May 4th.
And thanks to ACR and Stand Up to Cancer, many of
these efforts are funded
through various mechanisms, and these are some of the
collaborators we pulled in over the years because this disease
is definitely in the United States, a relatively orphan disease,
where we don't have big
foundations throwing
millions of dollars at it. And so to have some
key aspects of this funded through ACR and
Stand Up to Cancer, Turkoos, Gemini, Debbie's Dream Foundation
has been amazing.
So in conclusion, what we're seeing here is a shift in
paradigm where we're able to push the envelope and cure more
patients. Because I think historically, this
focus on palliation and just prolonging survival,
this nihilistic approach has been centered in our
disease. But now we're seeing even in metastatic, but certainly in
early-stage disease, people are being cured.
And what drives these cures is early immune priming,
generating deep responses that will enable organ
preservation. What we need to really understand is the tumor
biology, including the spectrum of chromosomal instability,
innate immune signaling, and that will shape immune response and
interrogate all the biomarkers
dynamically as we're really understanding how these tumors
adjust and change
while on treatment. And only working together in collaboration
can we do this.
We have an amazing team at MSK.
I see patients in a day, 30 patients in a day.
So really it takes a village to cure these
patients.
Really dedicated symptom management nursing care
is a big part of this. And so thank you for attending the session,
and I bought us four more minutes, so we have more time.
So I have a few questions from the floor as well.
Maybe I would like to invite Dr. Jenny to come up.
We can have a group Q&A.
So first, I have a question from
the
internet audience for Dr.
Yelena. In view of current guidelines, do you
offer to diffuse TPS less than one and
or node negative?
Yes.
The answer is?
Okay.
So the second question. In view of the negative results
for KN-525 and
innovation studies, what would you assume make the
pembro trastuzumab combo work?
Well, KEYNOTE-585 used a doublet,
and
we are seeing combination therapies with FLOT-based
regimen. I think if we wanted to talk about things why
585 was negative, we would need another 20 minutes.
But
in short, it's the combination of trastuzumab, pembrolizumab
together with FLOT
that
is what's driving these responses because if you remember, our initial
Phase 2 data of CAPOX, pembro/trast showed
100% disease control rate, and even in the large Phase 3
KEYNOTE-811 study, the complete response rate was
20%, so in the metastatic setting.
So really, it's not a difference between, I think
we need to be very clear.
In this case, anti-PD-1 therapy, anti-PD-L1 therapy,
these agents are equivalent. It's really not because of pembro versus durva,
why Matterhorn was different. It's the change in the
backbone, but also in a clinical trial design.
It was much more simple, and I would say elegant design.
So there's questions or-
Christoffer has opinions about that .
Yes. So I personally don't believe that addition of
taxane would change the outcome like that
in context of immunotherapy, because there are many trials from
China now
without a taxane showing benefit.
So I think
going forward, we will have to
focus on what you mentioned, is the more underlying
biomarkers in addition to a PD-L1.
Philip Dennis from Novo North-
I would just clarify that, of course, I think there's a
different in biology. We're dealing with G junction tumors, and I
think there may be some difference in that.
But please go ahead.
Philip Dennis from Novo Bridge. I have a question about claudin 18.2 expression.
For Dr. Leong first, in your metaplastic organoids,
claudin 18.2 was decreased. So is
cell surface 18.2 really only evident when
cells are fully transformed and when
truly malignancy is present?
So I think claudin 18 actually is a lineage
marker. I don't think it's a
neoplastic marker.
So is that-
Well, its
subcellular localization changes, right?
That's the dogma, that it's a tight junction-
Mm-hmm
... protein that's accessible in the cell surface-
...
in pancreatic BTC and gastric cancers, right?
Mm-hmm.
But I'm curious when in the process of
transformation that takes place.
I didn't know if you have data to that question.
Yeah, so my belief is because it's a gastric lineage marker
and during the metaplastic process, what we are
seeing is in some metaplasia when especially
it become very advanced intestinal, the gastric lineage markers
start to reduce.
So this is what we're talking about in the metaplastic process.
So I'm not sure whether in the cancer it could undergo the same
types of... Because, a lot of gastric cancer actually has
inherent probably metaplasia as the
stem cells. So,
it depends on the state. If it's a hybrid, it may still
retain the claudin 18, but it may switch to more
intestinal phenotype. I suppose that could be a form of resistance.
Is locally advanced, resectable,
is the prevalence of 18.2 the same as in metastatic?
Has anyone looked at that?
I think
it depends on which antibody. I find that the claudin
expression is really variable depending on who's looking at
the, and what cutoffs you use. But in our experience so far, it's very similar.
I had a question for you.
Mm-hmm.
So, as you know, the young onset is an
epidemic for our disease as well.
How do they develop? What type of metaplasia are you seeing in
young patients with this disease?
Have you looked at- You mean in gastric cancer?
Yeah.
I think it's
the same metaplasia.
Mm-hmm.
And I also find it, the complete and
incomplete classification,
I think
it's always a spectrum. And
if you look at the heterogeneity we see in the microdissected individual
gland, so if you look at it carefully, often you will see both
complete and incomplete in the same patient.
So it's really which one eventually gained
enough driver mutation to get transformed.
And it looks like based on our data, the
one that are more hybrid, that probably are more
likely to progress because of this plasticity
and fetal reversion.
Yeah. But they can, I think if you look at the
clonal organoid, they show different spectrum, right?
So I think to start with, the cell that turn
neoplastic probably
may have certain epigenetic point to start
with. But whether they can still deviate afterwards,
I'm not sure.
Yeah.
Well, a very nice presentation. I have three
questions. First is, if you only observe a single
tumor in a patient but you have so many mutations in the gastric
mucosa, why is it that we see only one tumor?
So what is the difference?The second question is, if we see
so many heterogeneities, and
metastases, and primary tumor,
how do we handle that in diagnostics?
Because all we have is the primary biopsy.
The third question is, we do have sexual dimorphism.
I haven't heard anything about how you treat women and men separately, how you
incorporate this information about sexual dimorphism in treatment and
diagnostics of gastric cancer.
Thank you. So for the first question about the heterogeneity,
I think it's kind of a few effect. So I think the difficulty
is, if you look at the heterogeneity, basically, there are many,
many glands, each acquiring their
mutation, the chromosome change independently.
But the chance of any one of them progress is pretty low.
So that's why at the end of the day, you end up mainly with one
dominant cancer. But I think in the early cancer
evolution, you may have many different parallel evolution
clones, but eventually, maybe one out-compete all the
others. So that's the answer to point number
one. So that's why by the time we see the gastric cancer, it usually
originate from one clone.
The sec-
Fitness. It's fitness, right? Fitness.
Yes. Yeah, exactly.
Many mutation in the gastric mucosa, you say you have shown that.
Yeah.
One eventually will develop into cancer.
What happens to the remainder?
I think it's not so easy to developing
cancer, so they
may remain as metaplasia, they may become dysplastic, but
they may be still in the field in the adjacent area.
Yeah.
So how we cope with diagnostics?
Maybe I can take that one. Yeah. I think what
we really need to cope with is, and it's a circular
argument, but right now the diagnostics are actually quite good, it's the
therapeutics that are lacking. So the truth is, yes, there is some
heterogeneity, but there's not that much of a difference between the
primary and the met. The p53 mutation is the same.
I would say
70% or 80% of
genomic alterations, if you sequence both, are very similar.
The difference comes in maybe some levels of expression of
HER2 or PD-L1 and so forth, but they probably aren't
that important to begin with, right?
So I think what we need to catch up on is actual
better therapeutics,
and the diagnostics then will lead.
Functional imaging, as Jeffrey said, and it's logical, you can't biopsy
all the mets anyway. So
I think what
we've developed is functional imaging, so using
radio tracers as a way to really just get a sense from the patient
what level of the burden of the biomarker they have.
And then you could prior strata...
You think the tumor is HER2 positive, but then you go in and only
60% or 70% of the primary tumor in the met
express, and we see that with HER2 PAT.
80% of patients have heterogeneity. We know that.
But if you don't have an alternative to target, you will still use HER2.
You'd need to develop other treatments before, and I think
it's fine to do it in parallel, but the field of therapeutics has really
lacked in this disease.
Thank you very much.
Yep.
This side. Yes.
Hi, my name is Chandra Gul. I'm a general surgery resident and a postdoc
in surgery at Stanford. Thank you for an excellent talk.
This is a question for Dr. Chen Zhijian. Hopefully, I'm saying your name right.
Yes.
You spoke about the neoadjuvant immuno-chemotherapy
and how that's becoming the gold standard for gastric cancer.
I wonder if you have any perspective on the extent of
lymphadenectomy that we currently do as a surgeon.
I know a lot of the Eastern perspective historically is doing pretty aggressive
lymphadenectomy, and that's what used to be considered adequate.
Now with immunotherapy, are we thinking about leaving some behind
for adequate therapy or response?
Curious to hear your thoughts.
Yeah. So looking at the pancreas experience with Vinod
Balachandran and the adjuvant vaccines, I think your
point is well taken. Sometimes these lymph nodes are important.
In fact, doing a splenectomy and taking out more lymph nodes was
associated with less of immune response.
For our disease, it's slightly different because we're doing everything
neoadjuvantly, and I think where the field is moving forward to doing more and
more while the tumor and the lymph nodes are in place, and
using surgeries almost as a staging
procedure where you have to take a lot of lymph nodes out, so you
know sort of what it-- Because first of all, you're worried that there's residual
disease, but also to adequately stage.
So I don't see the field-- In fact,
right now, I think that what I struggle most is as I'm
selecting centers or designing the next phase three, is
quality control. Because with the surgeons,
it's just you and the patient, and maybe some nurses
that report to you and would never tell you, "Well, your surgery was not good
enough." Right? So,
that's what we struggle with. And also the fact that
if you do have a good immune response, sometimes it looks like the lymph nodes are
growing, but in fact, they're all
residual response of therapy. So we have not
deescalated surgery. I think maybe that's going to be
in the next phase. But I see it's either all or
nothing. You either do the surgery or you don't.
But right now, the D2 lymph node dissection is the same.
It's a modified version where they leave the spleen behind.
Thank you.
I have a couple of questions, Dr. Judkins.
The first one regarding you are showing
the STING pathway, STING, cGAS pathway,
the increase the STING pathway can associate the poor survival.
But STING actually innate immune can increase the interferon gamma
or
actually anti-tumor. I don't know what's behind the rationale for
this poorly differentiation association with this high STING
pathway as a first pass.
I know. I knew that it was going to be very controversial
because you could approach it from two different factors.
And I suspect that in each individual tumor type, but
also within each even
gastroesophageal cancer, depending on where in the
trajectory of the CIN tumor you look, STING can be a good thing
or a bad thing.
So in our cohort
now, what we're seeing is that
we are seeing low STING expression.
STING pathway through interferon gamma can
up-regulation PD-1. I'm not sure in this patient
you gave additional PD-1 or PD-L1 treatment.
Do they have a better response or not?
So the cohort we have are all IO-treated
patients, so that's why we know what immunotherapy response or duration of
treatment
benefit was.
And what we are seeing is
these were pre-treatment samples.
Okay.
So these were not
one sort of post-progression samples, post immunotherapy.
Another question regarding to Dr. Johnny Bo, for you because you treat the patient.
I'm wondering because diffuse type of intestinal have
different etiology and molecular biology and the genetic
difference, do you treat the patient different or similar?
Based on what?
So I think pure diffuse type
of tumor patients, they do very badly
generally. But we start with the biomarkers,
the four biomarkers that Yelena showed,
and then you can do NGS.
But consistently, the diffuse type will do poorly.
Maybe with claudin, they will do a little bit better.
But
we don't treat based on phenotype.
We're treating based on biomarkers and
other profiling.
Okay. Another question also both to yours
regarding the immune therapy. I know PD-1,
PD-L1 mostly is tested in the clinical.
However, do you ever treat a patient and use TIGIT?
You mentioned the TIGIT plus PD-1.
Are there other LAG-3 or other?
Do you have any better clinical response than PD-1, PD-L1?
Yeah. So the TIGIT story, unfortunately, is negative as many other tumor
types. So there was a large Phase III study that will be
presented at ESMO GI in Munich
that was negative despite very promising Phase II study.
And LAG-3 data is also negative, unfortunately.
So the only hope is with PD-1 CTLA-4 because of
this Catenilimab FC silent
bispecific. But it's too soon to say because
the Nivo/Ipi data, the CheckMate 649 data looked
promising. But because there was no chemo, because of the
toxicity concern, there was a crossover in the survival curves.
So it's too soon.
The new bispecifics are going to probably
produce good results. So one
anti-PD-1, anti-PD-L1,
anti-VEGF,
or
EGFR HER3 with ADC,
they are showing some
good progress. But a lot of work needs to be done.
Okay.
Yeah. One question for Dr. Leung
on the cancer evolution
in this field. I'm curious if we can detect what's
going on during the pre-cancer to cancer, the
transition.
Yes. Any genomic bottlenecks during
the transition pre-cancer to cancer?
You show the mutation cluster, you use the mutation
and the epigenomic and the copy number, and do you have
a chance to check the timing of this event?
And the ultimate question is, can we detect, as
you say, the diagnosis is good. Is it possible to
detect cancer in pre-cancer stage if, say, we have the
precursor? That's my question.
Thank you.
So I think there is an intense interest in
predicting which metaplasia will progress to cancer, right?
I think the problem is for the metaplasia,
it's quite common, but only a small percent progress.
So you need to find ways to predict the one that will progress.
So based on our organoid model, we feel that those
metaplasia with chromosome 20 gain is probably
biologically, at least from our model, seems to have more
neoplastic phenotype. So in parallel, I also
cite some study, for example, from Singapore
groups. So they actually have other risk progression
marker like mutation count, even clonal
hematopoiesis, and ARID1A
mutation. So I think this is still work in progress.
But
I think with more data and more biology, I think for certain we should
be able to find better markers.
Thank you.
Yes.
The last question? Yeah.
Yeah, I have one question. Thank you for the nice talking.
The question for Dr. Elena.
In
new adjuvant in MSI-H patients, you
showed your clinical trials that combined dual
IO with chemotherapy, the effect is better.
But have you ever compared single IO with
chemotherapy and dual IO with
chemotherapy in this kind of patients?
Because in many clinical trials, single IO with
chemotherapy has already pretty
good effect.
That's a great question, and I will cover some of this in the
discussion. It's actually not my data, it's Alberto's data, Infinity,
and Sara Leonardi is here too. So they're presenting the
durva/tremi. But that's a very good question.
I think because of the heterogeneity in MSI cancers,
we know that anti PD-1, like dostorlimab data, right, in
gastroesophageal cancer was not as good as it was in rectal.
So at a minimum, chemoimmunotherapy is needed.
But I think CTLA-4 is a very attractive option
because we know from CheckMate 649,
looking at, at least numerically, we never compared head to
head, but FOLFOX nivo versus nivo ipi,
it looked better in terms of, again, small numbers, hard to
extrapolate. But we know that if you respond to ipi, you never progress,
right? So we know that.
And also FOLFOX is not easy. And in Alberto's study,
doing one dose of tremi is enough. So instead of
being on six months of FOLFOX nivo
or a flott durva, certainly, it's very appealing.
So I think the way that we approach it is that we usually start
with dual immune checkpoint blockade, but we watch the patient very
carefully, and if it looks like radiographically or clinically they're
progressing or not responding, we then pivot to either
flott durva or FOLFOX durva or something like that.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm. But come to the session on Tuesday. There'll be a lot more on that.
Okay. So thank you very much for your attendance.
And I also want to thank the speakers. Thank you.
We should take a picture.
Yeah.
We should take a picture together.
Thank you for the invitation.
Yeah. Enjoyed it.